juanita grand grand wants to know i
recall him talking about the temperature
and dryness of the air inside the craft
i would like to know if he's noticed
anything else strange obviously there's
plenty strange but something else that
you haven't
spoken much about if not at all
not really just uh
i was
feeling injured and so maybe
uh the suffocating feeling came from
that but
um the the human-looking
being who took me out of there was
wearing a helmet on his head so that was
probably i would think to protect him
from the atmosphere in there
um
or maybe to
avoid contaminating the interior of the
craft i don't know but um it does
suggest that
perhaps that was the reason
it did feel immediately cooler
and easier to breathe as soon as we got
outside
outside the initial room whereas you
could still be inside the craft into the
larger hanger room
see to me when i'm visualizing this i
only think in terms of craft so i think
in terms of this is a small craft inside
a larger craft but the way you're
describing it is this it's as if it's
or craft inside of a large building
somewhere it could be just a hanger on
the ground somewhere
if you have to make a guess as to how
large it was how many feet away could
you see your meters how large would you
characterize it well before i quote a
figure i really ought to get meditate on
that a bit you know figure out what the
size would be it was quite a bit larger
big enough for these things to fly into
i would assume they flew in there i
didn't see them flying
i know you said you need to think about
it some more
more than four times the size of the
initial place
is that correct
yeah
more
i'm a man of details travis more than 10
times
i would say you know got to be bigger
than 200 feet you know if there's
uh a couple of craft in there 40 feet in
diameter
um that adds up to 80 but they're spaced
by maybe 30. you know i'm just off the
top of my head saying
a figure like that